now we have a much
easier path because the democrats will
come to us
with a plan for infrastructure a plan
for health care a plan
for whatever they are looking at and
we'll negotiate
and as you know it's been very hard in
the senate because we need
essentially 10 votes from democrats and
we don't get those of us because the
democrats do really stick together well
i don't agree with them on a lot of
policy but i agree with them on sticking
together they stick together great
so now we go into the senate we don't
have the 10 votes
and what happens it doesn't get passed
even if it gets out of the house it
doesn't get passed so under the new
concept of what we're doing
i say come on let me see what you have
they want to do things you know i keep
hearing about
investigations fatigue like from the
time
almost from the time i announced i was
going to run they've been
giving us this investigation fatigue
it's been a long time they got nothing
zero you know why because there is
nothing but they can play that game but
we can play it better
because we have a thing called the
united states senate
and a lot of very questionable things
were done
between leaks of classified information
and
many other elements that should not have
taken place and all you're going to do
is end up in back
and forth and back and forth and two
years is going to go up
and we won't have done a thing i really
think and i
really respected what nancy said last
night
about bipartisanship and getting
together and uniting she used the word
uniting and she used the
the bipartisanship statement which is so
important because that's what we should
be doing
so we can look at us they can look at us
then we can look at them and it'll go
back and forth and it'll probably be
very good for me politically i could see
it being extremely good
politically because i think i'm better
at that game than they are actually
but uh we'll find out i mean you know
we'll find out or we can work
together you can't do them
simultaneously by the way just think of
somebody's oh you can do about no you
can't
because if they're doing that we're not
doing the other just so you understand
so we won't be doing that but now what
happens
is we send it to the senate and we'll
get 100
democrat support and we'll get some
republican support
and if it's good i really believe we
have republicans that
will help with the approval process and
they will really help with the approval
process
so it really could be a beautiful
bipartisan type of situation if we won
by
one or two or three or four or five that
wouldn't happen
and the closer it is the worse it is
this way
they'll come to me we'll negotiate maybe
we'll make a deal maybe we won't
that's possible but we have a lot of
things in common on infrastructure
we want to do something on health care
they want to do something on health care
there are a lot of great things that we
can do together
and now we'll send it up and we will
really get we'll get the democrats that
will get
the republicans or some of the
republicans
and i'll make sure that we send
something up that the republicans can
support
and they're going to want to make sure
they send something up that the
democrats can support